[Musique]
donc atteint
perché sur le toit du monde aux confins
du népal
voici l'ancien royaume du mustang dans
l'himalaya
un paysage désertique à plus de 3000
mètres d'altitude
sur ce territoire l'un des plus isolés
de la planète
des hommes et des femmes ont bâti une
cité fortifiée dès le 14e siècle
lowman tang l'un des plus beaux villages
du monde a résisté au temps et aux
envahisseurs
vous voyez ce mur qui fait le tour du
village là c'est une forteresse nous
avons aussi des tours de garde ici et là
il y en a aussi là il y en a 14 ans
ce système de défense a été conçu pour
nous protéger des ennemis qui venaient
du nord et du sud
parcourir la cité inscrite au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco c'est s'enfoncer
dans un labyrinthe de ruelles tortueuses
un dédale keim faire découvrir ses rimes
sambo visiteurs mais voilà c'est chez
moi
dans sa maison comme partout alomene
tang malgré le froid extrême
l'électricité n'est assurée que quelques
heures par jour
ce que tu as bien rentrer les vaches
et parce qu'il n'ya pas de forêt aux
alentours il n'ya pas non plus de bois à
brûler redoute pour se chauffer les
habitants utilisent de la bouse de vache
sécher
le plus difficile ici c'est quand il
neige beaucoup ça recouvre toute notre
maison et on a du mal à la faire partir
et à s'occuper de nos bêtes pour les
emmener boire jusqu'à la rivière
encerclé par les plus hauts sommets de
l'himalaya
lo manthang est au coeur d'un vaste
désert d'altitude
une terre aride où la récolte des fruits
et légumes n'a lieu qu'un mois par an
le reste du temps le village vit surtout
de l'élevage
notamment celui de yack l'animal
emblématique de l'himalaya
tatin date je vais les laisser derrière
la montagne je viendrai aller chercher
ce soir mais
cet éleveur possède un troupeau de 30
bêtes qu'il fait petra 4000 mètres
d'altitude
l'été j'aime aller encore plus haut dans
la montagne en ce moment nous restons
ici car c'est là qu'on troupe de l'herbe
c'est difficile d'élever des yaks en
cette saison les animaux sauvages
attaques souvent mon troupeau toute la
nuit je dois rester éveillé pour les
protéger des loups et des léopards des
neiges
anciens royaumes mystérieux le mustang
est resté jusqu'en 1992 interdit d'accès
aux touristes étrangers
aujourd'hui encore pour protéger la
région du tourisme de masse les
visiteurs doivent demander un permis de
400 euros
halloween tang les doyenne du village
fileuse de laine aimerait voir ces
restrictions levé car à qui on a ce
serait bien de baisser le prix de ce
permis car nous plus on est touriste
plus notre village se développe
comment faire pour les touristes qui
n'ont pas cet argent pour eux ça serait
bien de baisser les prédateurs la
capitale d'une terre de solitude et de
silence lowman temps j'ai aussi un haut
lieu du bouddhisme tibétain
la région est jalonnée de milliers de
grottes troglodytes dans lesquelles les
moines comme pemba talent j aime se
recueillir
suis tellement heureux d'être ici
regardez sur les cargos une fois par an
il se rend dans l'une d'elles pour
méditer à plus de 4500 mètres d'altitude
et après 1h d'ascension bemba taji
découvre enfin ce qui constitue l'un des
plus beaux trésors de la région du
mustang
ces grottes qui datent du 12e siècle
sont ornés de peintures sacrées
vous lassez bouddha est ici ce sont ses
disciples et là de jeunes moines tabac
dans le passé les moines et mes prières
et 6 où il ne pouvait être dérangé ni
par les humains ni par les animaux
petit paradis perdu aux confins du népal
le mustang longtemps isolé a traversé
les siècles préservant ses secrets et
ses grottes cacher